es posible que a usted o a un ser
querido le hayan diagnosticado leucemia
este video lo ayudará a comprender más
sobre este tipo de Cáncer y Cómo afecta
su
cuerpo su sangre contiene líquido y tres
tipos de células glóbulos rojos glóbulos
blancos y plaquetas estas células Se
forman en el centro esponjoso de sus
huesos conocido como la médula ósea
todas las células sanguíneas provienen
de la las células precursoras conocidas
como las células madre los glóbulos
rojos transportan oxígeno a los tejidos
de su cuerpo las plaquetas ayudan a que
la sangre coagule y los glóbulos blancos
ayudan a su cuerpo a combatir
infecciones y cualquier otro Invasor
dañino o
enfermedad la leucemia Es un cáncer que
se origina en ciertos glóbulos blancos
mientras se están formando en la
leucemia la células madre de la médula
ósea producen demasiados glóbulos
blancos anormales que no funcionan
correctamente esto debilita su sistema
inmunológico la leucemia también puede
reducir la cantidad de plaquetas y de
glóbulos
rojos los principales tipos de leucemia
se nombran por las células en las que se
originan y por la rapidez con que se
desarrollan por ejemplo la leucemia
linfocítica afecta a los glóbulos
blancos conocidos Como linfocitos en
esta enfermedad demasiadas células madre
linfoides se convierten en linfocitos
anormales la le mieloide afecta a los
glóbulos blancos conocidos Como células
mieloides en este tipo de cáncer
demasiadas células mieloides se vuelven
anormales y se dividen en mieloblastos o
granulocitos anormales que son
diferentes tipos de glóbulos
blancos cada tipo de leucemia puede ser
aguda lo que significa que progresa
rápidamente o Crónica lo que significa
que se desarrolla con el tiempo los
síntomas de la leucemia varían según el
tipo de leucemia y según las células
sanguíneas afectadas
a veces la leucemia no presenta síntomas
pero en general los síntomas pueden
incluir sensación de mucho cansancio y
debilidad moretones y sangrar fácilmente
fiebre pérdida de peso e infecciones
frecuentes como parte del diagnóstico su
médico tratará de averiguar el tamaño de
los tumores cancerosos Y si el cáncer se
ha
diseminado esto se denomina
estadificación la estadificación varía
según los diferentes tipos de leucemia
en general una etapa o fase más temprana
implica un menor crecimiento y
diseminación del cáncer una etapa o fase
más alta implica un mayor crecimiento y
diseminación del cáncer por todo el
cuerpo no se conoce la causa de la
leucemia Pero algunas cosas pueden
aumentar su
riesgo estar expuesto a altas dosis de
radiación tener ciertos genes
anormales infección con ciertos virus
como el virus de epstein
bar exposición a largo plazo aciertos
químicos tales como benzeno y
medicamentos de quimioterapia fumar y
una edad
avanzada mientras vive con su
diagnóstico de leucemia continúe
hablando con su médico y con el equipo
de atención médica contra el
cáncer